hello everyone and welcome back to
Denver Colorado it's a Game three of the
1971 semi-final match between Bobby
Fischer and bent Larsen
now as you seen both the game 1 and game
2 went went in Bobby's favor in Game one
he Fisher played that a brilliant rook
captures on e5 move followed by Bishop
to c5 and in game number 2 it seemed all
was going well Larsen did have a draw
position at some point he was even
better
but then again Fisher found that
brilliant rook to e4 move which India
the one hinder game so now again Fischer
has the white pieces and again a Larson
has to decide will he go like in Game
one with the French defense or will he
try something else just a second so we
do have one photo as we've already seen
it but just you know so we get in the
mood there we have it Fisher versus one
Larsen at temple college in Denver
Colorado now let's see what happened in
Game three and you know if if anything
Larsen kind of kind of knows how mark
Temenos felt when he was playing his
match against Bobby Fischer but it's not
only Fischer that's happy for his two to
zero result before game 3 also marked a
Manoff ended the Soviets are also kind
of happy about this result as you know
the more fear if Fischer beats everyone
else the less will be the shame for mark
Temenos
and the Soviets so let's see Fischer of
course once again goes for e4 we have c5
this time Larsson goes for the Sicilian
defense Knight to f3 d6 d4 C captures
the knight captures and Knight to f6 now
so ok Knight to c3 under nice the c6 now
we have Bishop to c4 the sawsan attack
east 6 transposing into the Scheveningen
and now Bishop to b3 a Fischer goes for
his signature move Bishop to e7 now
comes Bishop to e3
we have castles f4 Bishop to d7 and now
comes castles by Fischer a6 and now the
early f5 this is still standard theory
of this of this variation and here well
the standard theory
says that in those days you should have
exchanged the nights here on d4 even
sooner than this and here what you want
to do is definitely do it now after
captures captures ePHI view push the
bishop back but the c6 the game
continues always worldwide a slightly
better about two deaths or all all
standards but after this f5 move and
remember this is still only moved 11
here Larsson plays Queen to c8 so he
brings more defenders to the e6 pawn but
this is actually a terrible move this is
actually a blunder now you don't really
have all that many options official
place F captures on e6 and now you don't
have the option of playing F captures on
e6 because of this nice to f5 move now
your d6 pawn is under attack twice Queen
c7 defending now comes the Bishop to f4
again with a triple attack against the
d6 point you can push f5 because the
pawn is pinned here so what do you do
Queen b6 check King moves and here
pretty much everyone agrees that this
position would be winning for white
because the advantage you're simply too
vast King h8 I have to unpin but now
simply Knight captures captures and here
you grab the pawn but your captors on d6
Queen captures probably is also possible
but Bishop captures is a bit stronger so
here you grab a pawn your position is
much better and well everyone in those
days agreed that this would have been
winning and of course today so after F
captures on e6 Bishop captures and e6
was played by Larsson but now this again
loses but it wasn't all that clear at
the time the game was played how it
loses first played Knight captures on e6
you have F captures on e6 and now it's
very interesting this is only moved 13
larsson now Fischer now has to make move
14 and already it seems like a wonderful
position for black you have your Knights
are nicely developed your Bishop is
occupying the nice e7 square you have a
very nice center here and your rooks are
here where they should be you have a
semi-open file for the rook so it seems
like black is perfectly fine here but as
in game 2 and also is in game 1
there is one move that
Larsson overlooked feel free to pause
the video here and find it the only move
a official can play to push for
advantage here so I'll give it a couple
of seconds for it to decide what do you
want to do it or not for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are really an excellent player
finding these fish removes here fish are
played in Nice 284 and it seems like a
really odd move why would you play it in
nice to a for bringing the night over to
the edge of the board everyone knows
that the night on the rim is grim but
it's actually a beautiful move
the threat is nice to be six if night
comes to be six then of course you will
lose the exchange here and there isn't
all that much you can do here you can't
move the Queen because the Queen has to
keep a defending d6 pawn as the bishop
is attacking that also the pawn is
pinned one thing you can do and the only
thing you can do is move the rook which
was played in the game rook to b8 but
special place tonight the b6 all the
same now the problem for Larsson is that
the knight is attacking the Queen but
also guarding the d7 square so the Queen
is out of squares where she can guard
the e6 pawn so Queen to e8 was played by
Larsson and he refresher simply captured
the pawn bunch of characters on e6 with
check King h8 and now Bishop to f5
Fischer has the bishop prepare his night
is beautiful placed on b6 he's up a pawn
so everything goes in his favour and
he's already in the lead two points in
this in this match so this is truly
truly these are dark times for Ben
flossin but ok 95 we have Queen to d4
now this beautiful centralizing move
with the Queen as well Queen to h5 and
here comes Knight to d5 here Fischer
wants to exchange some pieces he's up
material and here if you play something
like Knight e to g4 which ideas of
giving up some material for this Queen
captures on h2 it doesn't really make
all that much sense Bishop to f4 simply
defends everything and now you have the
exchange and all is well Rosewall for
white here so after 95 a Larson played
Knight captures on d5 we have Queen
after sandy 5 and now Queen to e2
attacking the bishop here
pressuring the c2 pawn so what do you do
here first Fisher could definitely move
this Bishop to d4 d4 is an excellent
square for the bishop but first fish
replace Bishop to a7
he wants the he wants to try and get
this rook to come to a8 to attack the
bishop where he can either capture the
b7 pawn or only now retreated to d4 but
first he wanted to bring Larson's rook
to a less active square so okay after
Bishop to a7 a rugby t8 was played by
Larsen and the now comes rook to f2 a
Fisher doesn't Fisher doesn't want to
capture on b7 and all our Queen captures
on c2 first he kicks away the Queen and
doesn't allow the Queen to capture on c2
we have Queen to be 5 and the now c3
again
fisheries has a better position he's up
in material a highly-placed
c3 now the rook is guarding the b2 pawn
and he offers a trade of Queens Bishop
to h4 and now the simple g3 taking the
bishop back Fischer still only in
improves his position Queen captures
pawn captures the Queens gets traded off
and now Bishop active f6 and the rook a
to f1 doubling up doubling up rooks and
EF file Knight to c4 and now comes
Bishop to Bishop to e6 closing down the
e-file rook to e8 attacking fresh versus
Bishop Bishop to d4 Fischer even doesn't
mind doubling up his D pawns as he's
very confident in his technique to win
this Bishop captures pawn captures and
now rook captures an f2 rook captures
and b5 King to f1 Fischer bring starts
bringing his King into the game g6 and
now b3 kicking the knight back and now
you have a problem here
Knight b6 will be met with rook to c2
the knight the bishop controls the night
and also the rook is guarding in the
entire C file this night I will no
longer be able to join the rest of her
Black's forces and rook the c6 is coming
so after b3 you can always go for a
night to e3 check but then comes King e2
and after Knight to a5 Bishop captures
pawn captures you can simply grab
another pawn and now you simply have too
much material
so after b3 knife to a3 was played and
comes King he to simply improving the
position of the King Rock a seven and
since now the rock did leave the bank
back rank official goes rook to f8 check
came to g7 and now rock to d8 attacking
the d6 pawn we have B for rock character
song d6 and now Knight to b5 attacking
the rook and also the d4 pawn rook to b6
and Knight captures and now King to d3
we have Knight captures and e6 and here
rook captures on e6 also possible was
Knight captures only pawn captures an e6
but this allows the King to stop the
pawn much better is rook captures and
now the rook completely cuts off the
King from ever joining the game and the
white simply has to bring his king over
here and start pushing in the past pawn
and it's game over
there is nothing black can do to to
prevent losing this game if I was
playable arson king before king f7 and
here
rook to e2 was played so now the King is
completely cut off from the e-file and
Fischer will simply bring his King and
start pushing his pawn so it was in this
position on move 41 that bent Larsen
resigned Game three and Fischer is now
three three points in the lead 3 to 0
what if you resign well there's really
nothing to do if you try and prevent the
King from coming in simply d7 rogue d7
blocking King comes to d5 rogue d8 King
Kong c6 rook c8 check you attack the
rook rook attacks pawn king attacks rook
rook goes back d7 you can check and
after this King c6 rook checks King goes
here rook here you attack the King and
after the rook moves you will finally
bring a queen into the game but any any
series of moves will will have led to
this to the same outcome
so King if someone was played repeated
by Fischer and like I said it was in
this position that bent Larsen resigned
to the game and well this is basically
game number three I do hope you enjoyed
it and that you were enjoying the
coverage of the Fisher series so far and
that you are a little by little
improving your vast knowledge of this
you know entire event and of Bobby
Fischer and all the players he met
you know in his search for the chest
glory so I would like to thank Chris
Thorpe Tonelli Lauren Olli
Dennis Tomlinson Sir John ko-hoh and the
Joseph Burnett for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos see our thing called for
watching and I'll see you soon hopefully
with another interesting video have an
excellent rest of your Friday season